[Musique]
et
dans les séries télé on les appelle les
experts dans la vraie vie ils sont
gendarmes sur le terrain ou en labo il
aide les enquêteurs et les magistrats à
résoudre des enquêtes criminelles
ses expériences à faire parler la poudre
verdict l'armée fonctionne parfaitement
sur les scènes de crime
ils sont à l'affût du moindre indice
voilà là j'ai pratiquement le produit à
l'état brut ils savent déceler ce que
l'on ne voit pas à l'oeil nu
de prime abord plus dur ces experts sont
confrontés quotidiennement à la mort on
est jamais habitués ils mettent aussi et
c'est pas parce qu'on a fait des
dizaines des centaines que
on est habitué et même quand il n'y a
plus de corps à observer il y a toujours
un indice à dénicher déjà là on est
quasi sûr qu'on est en présence d'un cg
masculin c'est parti on vous embarque
avec les experts du crime
nous sommes au fort de rosny sous bois
en banlieue parisienne cette caserne du
19e siècle abrite 250 gendarmes à la
pointe de la modernité
des experts qui mènent l'enquêté de
manière scientifique
ici à l'institut de recherche criminelle
ircgn
on sait faire parler des ossements
humains on élève des insectes
on effectue des analyses très poussées
et on s'est même lire dans les lignes de
la main
tout cela dans un seul et même but
éclaircir les énigmes criminelles les
plus obscurs la visite commence à 10
mètres sous terre
voici l'un des endroits les plus secrets
du fort l'armurerie
le gendarme ronan le douaron et le
gardien de cette collection unique en
france
donc là on est au coeur de la collection
nationale des armes c'est un peu dans
une bibliothèque de référence ça nous
sert à comparer toutes les armes qui
arrivent chez nous à savoir s'ils sont
bien origines si elles n'ont pas subi de
modification ou 6,6 au contraire elles
ont été un peu bidouillé 7000 modèles
tout entreposées ici
ils permettent à ceux balisticien
d'expertisé les armes retrouvées sur les
scènes de crime
cela va de la kalachnikov soviétique
donc au fusil d'assaut du soldat ryan
ça par exemple celle qui fait aussi des
soldats américains dans le débarquement
alors pari si on a des armes mythiques
comme la célèbre thompson 1928 d'al
capone avec son chargeur camembert si
vous avez par exemple le pp cas de james
bond
toutes ces armes vous les connaissez
grâce au cinéma les armes plus
imposantes comme ça aussi sont assez
photogénique le desert eagle
celle-ci vous l'avez vu dans matrix ici
on a des choses qui tient un peu sur
l'espionnage comme les stylos pistolet
ça c'est vraiment destiné à au tir à
très courte distance mais celle que nous
allons vous présenter vous ne l'avez
jamais vu sur grand écran on a les armes
qui sont moins typiques comme les armes
artisanales qu'on retrouve chez les gens
des amateurs éclairés qui a essayé de
saisir ce qui était la quintessence
d'une arme donc contre toute attente ça
fonctionne et ça tue satire du calibre
22 long rifle
ça suffit ça suffit largement tuer
quelqu'un parce en arrière
ça ressemble à rien mais ça reste
efficace voilà ce passionné ne se
contente pas de veiller sur sa
collection
il est aussi capable d'expertisé
n'importe quelle arme
aujourd'hui ils s'intéressent à ces
pistolets alors ça c'est un pistolet
semi automatique qui a été découvert
chez une personne donc mise en cause
dans un homicide
et donc on va essayer déterminer ce que
c'est comme arme si c'était modifié et
surtout si c'est bien elle qui a pu
tirer sur la victime
ce calibre 11,43 de fabrication chinoise
est il d'origine pour le savoir notre
gendarme fait un tour dans sa drôle de
bibliothèque
ce que je vois c'est qu'on a des
différences de pièces ça peut être une
modification s'appelait d'origine ça
peut avoir fait avoir été fait après ça
peut nous permettre de déterminer une
année de fabrication et ça peut
permettre aussi de remonter aux
revendeurs éventuelles
deuxième étape vérifier que l'arm
fonctionne bien
pour cela il suffit de tirer et
attention aux oreilles père dit l'armée
fonctionne parfaitement
maintenant notre expert va isoler deux
cartouches qui serviront d'éléments de
comparaison avec celles retrouvées sur
la scène de crime pour récupérer les
projectiles
il va tirer dans ce sac par balles c'est
la simple fibre de coton qui en fait en
association avec le mouvement pendulaire
nu du tube va permettre d'arrêter des
projectiles relativement rapidement et
de les récupérer dans les sacs même
manière la moins déformée possible
voilà un projectile à notre expert a
donc récupéré deux projectiles et deux
douilles que l'on appelle aussi étui ces
étuis vont maintenant être comparés avec
ceux retrouvés sur la scène de crime
quand comment voilà les tirs effectués
et larmes
c'est le commandant petit qui va faire
parler l'original gauche nous avons mis
l'étui tir et qui a été retrouvée sur la
scène de crime et à droite on a mis les
pieds qui est issu des tirs qui ont été
faits tout à l'heure avec larmes
récupérer celle suspect et oui car
chaque arme imprime sa signature sur les
douves ya une signature particulièrement
visible à l'endroit où le percuteur
frappe la cartouche
donc on voit très bien la canton quand
on tourne l'étui on voit apparaître des
stries et le but c'est de voir si
l'autre élément l'élément de comparaison
possède également des stries et est ce
que ces stries on va pouvoir les faire
concorder avec trace d'un côté donc l'a
retravaillée par juxtaposition on voit
l'ensemble des éléments concorder au
niveau de la bourse et donc on va
pouvoir soutenir très fortement
hypothèse que c'était tiré par la même
arme
et voilà le tour est joué grâce à nos
experts on peut affirmer que le pistolet
suspect a été utilisée sur la scène de
crime
ali rcgm toutes les armes expertise et
passent d'abord ici au bureau des
scellés c'est une sorte de gare de
triage de toutes les pièces à
convictions passées au peigne fin par
nos experts
chaque jour l'adjudant chef thierry
grannec réceptionne classe et stocke des
dizaines d'objets en tout genre d'essai
les saisies sur le terrain qui provient
de toute la france il ya bien sûr des
armes mais pas seulement
on stocke aussi les cieux on a avoué
décédé de toute nature en fête
ce matin 6 pins de cannabis et 200
grammes d'herbe
ils seront analysés par les toxicologues
de lierre cgn
mais avant cela chaque seller doit
obligatoirement être enregistrées pour
assurer sa traçabilité
on a une base informatique qui nous sert
à suivre le stockage et ensuite les
divers échanges avec les départements
criminalistique de l'institut pour
savoir à un moment donné où est le célé
s'il est encore en stockage s'il est en
cours d'analysé ou s'il est prête à
repartir vers leur car en les scellés
sont ensuite stockés en rayon et des
rayons il y en a beaucoup
on a à peu près plus de 800 mouvement de
scellés par semaine à l'accueil donc à
chaque fois c'est une boîte avec un ou
deux ou trois scellés dedans donc il
faut les apporter à l'accueil finir les
rangées ici donc oui on fait énormément
de kilomètres non je n'ose une semaine
c'est assez sportif voilà il faut
s'entretenir physiquement chaque année
vingt mille seller arrive dans ce bureau
et on reparte après expertise ici il y a
même une salle dédiée aux pièces
encombrante un pare-chocs de véhicules
qui est en haut
1 ici on a une presse avec des fausses
plaques d'immatriculation après ici on a
une vitre de train ici et avec ses
milliers de scellés l'adjudant chef n'a
qu'une hantise perdre une pièce à
conviction
ça ne peut pas arriver du moins ce n'est
pas arrivé depuis novembre chez eux ici
on n'a pas perdu de céder ça ne doit pas
arriver à surtout pas avant d'arriver
ici
ces fameuses pièces à conviction ont été
saisis sur des scènes de crime par des
gendarmes spécialisés
les techniciens en identification
criminelle
[Musique]
nous voici à beauvais dans l'oise au
groupement départemental de la
gendarmerie
ces sommes sont techniciens en
identification criminelle des tic pour
faire court
leur rôle prélever des indices sur les
scènes d'infraction et comme tous les
lundis
c'est grand ménage à la caserne le
camion des tic n'y échappe pas
inventaire général avant intervention
bon ça c'est tout ce qu'ils équipent ans
terry l'un des pinces bruxelles
deschamps stérile x des ciseaux des
piluliers des écouvillon des cure-dents
de l'eau stérile
ça c'est pour des prélèvements certaines
des prélèvements biologiques dans ce
labo ambulants des équipements de toutes
sortes pour prélever des indices comme
celle où la plâtre poussé langue
spéciale qui révèle des traces qu'on ne
voit pas forcément empreintes digitales
ou fluides corporels ses larmes fétiche
des tic comme ça on peut dire si notre
pistolet est effectivement c'est ce
qu'on utilise de plus
inventaire terminée petit coup de
karcher maintenant pour la route
le camion et par et les opérationnels et
appartient à partir en intervention
le camion n'attendra pas longtemps au
garage première intervention avec
l'adjudant chef jean christophe poupart
et le maréchal des logis chef mickaël
rémond
un cadavre a été découvert alors ils se
rendent sur place
il s'agit d'un cycliste retrouvé mort le
long d'une route une mort
potentiellement suspectes pour le
procureur de beauvais
le parquet demande
le déplacement de la cellule ainsi que
d'un médecin légiste
pour
effectuer les constatations et vérifier
il s'agit d'une mort naturelle par un
arrêt cardiaque par exemple d'une mort
consécutive à un accident
vingt minutes plus tard arrivés sur les
lieux
l'adjudant-chef va d'abord se renseigner
auprès des gendarmes de la brigade
locale sur les circonstances de la
découverte du cadavre
tapez un nom
c'est les deux cyclistes qui découvrent
qu'ils découvrent le corps sur le bas
côté là le corps où il se trouve et le
et le vélo juste à côté c'est juste à
côté
ils ont transport et longs et loyaux à
la langue aujourd'hui d'accord ont
découvert ensuite le gendarme jette un
premier coup d'oeil aux cadavres
à première vue rien de suspect pour
l'instant il est bien trop tôt pour le
dire
on vient juste d'arriver en autant de
médecin légiste et l'examen de corps
nous en dira sûrement plus les gendarmes
tentent ensuite de trouver des traces de
pneus suspecte un véhicule aurait pu
percuter le cycliste avant de prendre la
fuite
il n'y a pas de trace de freinage sur
des véhicules tiers au niveau du lieu où
il est découvert on n'a pas de présence
cette possibilité d'avoir deux un choc
immédiat sur le véhicule sur son vélo
tout s'est donc l'examen du corps du
cycliste qui permettra d'en savoir plus
et ça c'est le travail du médecin
légiste qui vient d'arriver
mais avant cela il faut obligatoirement
revêtir une combinaison blanche pour ne
pas polluer les prélèvements qui seront
effectués sur le corps j'imitais trader
lens perd encore sous l'examen du corps
dure une bonne vingtaine de minutes
l'éthique place sous scellés plusieurs
prélèvements biologiques
elle a procédé à un prélèvement de sang
afin de pouvoir faire une analyse
notamment toxicologiques et et
alcoologie ya pas de clé par la blanche
porte clés par arme à feu
conclusion pas de pluie pas
d'exploration plutôt n'est pas de kimoce
pas de pelé arme blanche armes à feu
quand toulouse il n'y a pas de phase de
terrassement de serre s'ils voulaient le
doute est donc levé le cycliste n'a pas
été victime d'un accident de la route
ta s'oriente sur réellement vers un
décès d'origine naturelle affaire
classée
un peu plus tard nous retrouvons
nautique sur une scène d'infraction sans
cadavre cette fois la victime
c'est ce pavillon en ruines il a
entièrement brûlé quelques jours plus
tôt en l'absence de ces propriétaires
alors accidents incendies criminels
c'est la question que se pose le chef
christophe delattre perplexe devant
l'étendue des dégâts
ça vient ça je peux pas vous dire je
sais pas encore ce qu'on sait que le
collègue avec le chien spécialisé un
fonds dit et ce bon toutou s'appelle
jean
elle est accompagnée de son maître
l'adjudant jacques viguier
cette femelle berger malinois est doté
d'un ultra sensibles mais de papattes
fragile c'est pour ça qu'on lui met des
chaussettes pour la protéger des gravats
la voilà prête pour sa mission du juin
tenter de détecter ce qu'on appelle des
produits accélérant comme de l'essence
tout en s'amusant
parce que pour jenny chercher l'odeur de
ses produits
c'est comme jouer à la baballe
d'ailleurs son maître ne lui donne la
balle que lorsqu'elle marque un bon
droit suspect ça c'est bien ça voilà
donc le chien m'a marqué un endroit en
grattant et on se fixant sur la zone
précise je piquais tendre royal afin que
mes camarades de la silice et des
techniciens au monde
gascon criminels passent le prélèvement
poursuit pour déterminer s'il ya eu du
produit accélérant la rigueur c'est bien
ça choque comme il y aurait donc un
produit accélérant ce qui laisse
supposer qu'il s'agit d'un incendie
d'origine criminelle
d'ailleurs dans la pièce suivante
deuxième marquage
elle s'en met plein la truffe jenny
c'est une efficacité redoutable
[Musique]
un peu plus loin
troisième marquage cette fois même un
nez humain suffire
waouh je crée bien sûr mais là où qu'on
détecte et déjà sonné les odeurs de peu
de produits accélérants mission terminée
pour jenny qui a bien mérité ses
récompenses
voilà j'ai très bien maintenant les tic
vont vérifier si le chien a bien
travaillé avec ce drôle d'appareil
moi j'appelle ça me faire tout
simplement c'est le nez l'électronique
ok ça permet ce que vous faites ça
essaye misérablement de remplacer de
lucien confirmation du rhony flare le
compteur de l'appareil monte en flèche
on en arrive à 30 bon là on en a on a eu
quelque chose au sol voilà là j'ai
pratiquement le produit à l'état brut
là on est à 106 ce qui est non 108 mêmes
118 aucun doute possible il y a bien dû
produit accélérant les tic font des
prélèvements qui seront envoyés à lierre
cgn les experts de rosny sous bois
devront déterminer de quelle
hydrocarbures il s'agit tous
avant de repartir nous experts donnent
leurs conclusions au major chargé de
l'enquète tu peux obligatoire on
détermine par rapport à ces deux zones
déjà on est d'origine humaine et puis
j'ai vu le lieu c'est une origine
humaine ou même pas semblant pas aidé
dans la file en terre ou alors ce serait
vraiment il faudrait vraiment être con
il bourré pour pouvoir faire des
conneries de ce genre tout à fait mais
ce serait mais enfin bon c'est pas
logique si ce n'est pas accidentel
c'est donc criminels mais qui a incendié
ce pavillon retour à rosny sous bois
les prélèvements faits sur l' incendie
sont arrivés depuis deux jours au bureau
décennies passées les formalités
c'est l'adjudant thierry dusoulié qui va
analyser le contenu de ces bocaux en
verre envoyés par les tics de l'oise
la mission de ce gendarme chimiste
identifier le produit accélérant
répandue dans le pavillon dans son labo
notre sherlock holmes en blouse blanche
se lance dans une tambouille d'experts
nous introduisons un flacon en verre
dans le bocal avec les résidus donc le
produit éventuellement présents le
produit inflammable éventuellement
présentes et le matériau va libérer des
vapeurs qui vont être piégé ensuite dans
le flacon en verre mais c'est lui que
nous allons récupérer pour l'analyse et
pour libérer ces vapeurs il suffit de
faire chauffer au four pendant 45
minutes à 90 degrés ces prêts nos
chimistes récupère donc les petits
flacons qui ont emprisonné les vapeurs
de produits ces flacons vont ensuite
être déposé dans une machine qui va
analyser les vapeurs
ce robot donne ses conclusions sous
forme de courbes dans les vapeurs que
l'on a piégé dans le flacon nous avons
un ensemble de molécules donc qu'ils
vont être séparés par la machine chaque
pic que vous voyez ici à l'écran
représentant un composé donc présents
dans ce mélange de vapeur l'ensemble des
composés qui s'affiche à l'écran révèle
finalement le nom du produit mystère
ça y est l'adjudant ducelier à la
réponse avant de rédiger son rapport d
expertise
il passe un coup de fil au chef de
lattre qui a effectué les prélèvements
mais je t'appelle pour te communiquer
les résultats des analyses concernant la
recherche de produits accélérants donc
les résultats sont positifs pour les
trois prélèvements puisqu'on met en
évidence du gazole fin du carburant pour
véhicules diesel mail enquête est
toujours en cours
elle n'a pas encore permis d'identifier
l'auteur de l'incendié
bonne journée à bientôt pendant ce temps
là au bureau des scellés les arrivages
continue tiens par exemple dans cette
boîte blanche là qu'est ce qu'il y a aux
jeunes une tête je vais peut-être
g
un dossier g
j'ai pas mal de choses oui oui oui on en
a on en a régulièrement aussi on va
après pas tous les jours non plus mais
ça arrive il y a aussi des sabres
japonais qui ont peut-être un lien avec
la tête d'ailleurs bon une tête c'est un
seul et qui n'attend pas pour lamballe
donc vite et on les stocke tout aussi
vite on va aller déposer ce cd au
congélateur 1 comme il s'agit d'un
restes humains bon il ya une dégradation
avec des odeurs bien sûr donc il faut le
maintenir congelé pour qu'après ils sont
en plus exploitable nôtre c'est léo
congélateur bah c'est encore une fois
comme toujours ces divers on peut aussi
bien vend des restes humains du pardon
des vêtements prix fait des vêtements
trouvés sur sur un noyer ou autre ce
matin le congélateur va encore se
remplir alors là je suis en train de
récupérer
apparemment ce sont des doigts ouais des
doigts alors 1 2 3 4 5
une pochette par doit installer par
doigts voilà de 20 à 18 le compte est
bon
arrivées constituée d'un corps
presque presque nous manque encore des
morceaux quand même et pour ses doigts
même tarif que pour la tête
direction le congélateur hôpital de
creil dans l'oise
unité médico-judiciaire aujourd'hui
l'adjudant-chef poupart et le chef
raymond assiste à une autopsie
la veille une enquête judiciaire a été
ouverte pour meurtre
on est sur le plus tôt possible une
d'une dame qui ce qui a été découverte
hier décidé à son domicile
les autopsies est important pour nous
pour connaître exactement les causes de
la mort c'est un médecin légiste le
docteur marc lauba qui dirige
l'opération
il fait d'abord une première découverte
et là c'est une plaie saignante du cuir
chevelu à la face postérieure de la tête
donc au niveau occipital on va raser de
leur âge ou autour on vous laisse et
décidant de ne pas toucher trop à la le
coup porté à la tête
aurait-il causé la mort
rusé qu'il voulait retourner en
centimètres de long way
cette blessure n'a pas causé la mort
mais les gendarmes ont leur petite idée
ou qu'on cherche à déterminer si il y
avait eu ou non et doucement devant
de la victime aurait gentiment avec
précaution
c'est plus long c'est même très long
près de trois heures d'auto psy avec
quelques moments délicats à passer par
exemple ce bruit désagréable c'est le
son d'une scie électrique
elle permet d'ouvrir la boîte crânienne
[Musique]
on n'est jamais habitué à une autopsie
et c'est pas parce qu'on en a fait des
dizaines ou des centaines que bon
on est habitués ça reste quelque chose
de fort dans un moment fort à passer
mais
il est nécessaire pour l'enquêté
justement l'enquète du légiste progresse
l'observent des lésions des
des cornes de l'os hyoïde intervillages
thyroïde et donc en france est meilleure
preuve à la française ça veut dire qu'il
y a eu peut-être quelque chose une
manoeuvre traumatique alors un tel
niveau au niveau du cou la victime a
peut être subi un étranglement dernière
étape de l'autopsié
le relevé des empreintes digitales de la
victime celles ci seront comparées avec
les empreintes prélevés à son domicile
il est logique que de trouver la trace
digitale de la victime à son domicile
donc il est nécessaire de pouvoir
l'identifier
à partir du moment où celle ci serait
prélevée et si les enquêteurs trouvé des
empreintes digitales qui n'appartiennent
pas à la victime
cela pourrait les mettre sur la piste
d'un suspect
c'est pas mal
22 heures les techniciens en
identification criminelle de beauvais
partent en intervention sur une nouvelle
découverte de cadavres il s'agit d'un
homme retrouvé mort par son fils un
fusil à ses côtés suicide meurtre
l'adjudant michael ou shell doit en
savoir plus il appelle un gendarme sur
place c'est que moi je veux savoir
pourquoi été placé là précisément
d'accord ok je voudrais savoir également
la victime c'est des droitiers ou
gauchers
il retire pas
droitier gaucher
le grand synthois là dessus
sur les lieux du drame le gendarme qui
est intervenu le premier donne des
détails aux tic le physique la maison
dont il a entendu le coup de feu il est
allé voir et puis il a trouvé son père
tout au long du jardin donc allonger que
le fusil pour vérifier la version du
christ nos experts avons utilisé ces
petits tubes que l'on appelle des
tampons noir ce sont des tempes ou avec
une pastilla des îles ils permettent de
récolter d'éventuelles traces de poudre
à canon sur les mains ou le visage
ces témoins nous dit qu'il a pas qui
n'était pas présent au moment des faits
ça nous permet de corroborer ses dires
ou pas
si jamais on trouve des résidus de tir
sur cette personne sur ce témoin on
saura qu'ils nous mentaient qu'il était
au plus près de la scène
à ce moment là les tic vont ensuite
saisir de fusil retrouvez très du défunt
il l' expertise rond plus tard car
l'urgence c'est d'examiner le cadavre
qui se trouve au fond du jardin
par respect pour la famille évidemment
très choquée nous n'avons pas fini
retour une demi heure plus tard
alors s'agit-il d'un suicide l'adjudant
reste prudent pour l'instant il n'y a
aucune aucun témoin oculaire de la scène
personne n'est en mesure de dire
réellement ce qui s'est passé sur les
faits donc seules les concertations vont
parler seul en quête d'un pouvoir
déterminer si l'individu a mis
réellement fin à ses jours
un homicide maquillé ça peut se produire
également ça sans souci
fin d'intervention pour ces militaires
confrontés chaque jour à la mort le
chemin du retour est parfois propice aux
confidences
ouais ça
pourquoi ce retour
adam précis tour difficile quand on
arrive et qui à la famille qui est
présente
me présente
il ya une douleur
cette douleur de la famille
se protéger pour continuer à faire ce
métier sinon on arrête de 8
dgo dès qu'on les touche et de toute
manière j'ai connu des anciens thi kieu
avait été commencé à être touché par
cette douleur justement et qui ne
pourraient plus qu'ils reconnaissaient
eux mêmes ne plus pouvoir
réaliser leur métier tic
parce que quand il est arrivé
sur une scène cette scène
alors rappeler celle une autre scène
j'ai eu du mal à oublier
[Musique]
retour à la caserne pour expertiser
larmes
c'est un vieux fusil en mauvais état
l'etic prenne d'abord ces mesures la
bouche du canon au à la détente
oui sont 13es ces mesures là on va les
transmettre au directeur de l' enquête
qui pour avoir lors de l'examen de corps
avec le médecin légiste
si la mesure de l'armée compatible
parfait si la mesure de l'armée
compatible avec avec les bras la victime
pour une éventuelle autorisé un suicide
voilà un suicide
l'enquète conclura finalement que cet
homme s'est suicidé aujourd'hui la
lieutenant marion berlot seront à la
caserne de beauvais cet officier de
gendarmerie et psychologue elle va
rencontrer les techniciens en
identification criminelle de l'oise
essayer de discuter un peu de ce qu'ils
font au quotidien et surtout de
comment ils le vivent un fait comment il
arrive à prendre de la distance par
rapport à tout ça parce qu'il faut quand
même que quand même un métier qui est
assez bouaké assez difficile au
quotidien travailler sur des corses et
parano d'un des psys dans la gendarmerie
c'est assez récent la lieutenant berlot
a été recruté il ya un an
elle est spécialisée dans la prise en
charge des traumatismes psychiques
cette première séance sera collective
toute l'équipe est présente
on va commencer vous
on va essayer de faire en sorte que la
parole circule soit sans jugement le
l'idée c'est vrai que chacun puisse
s'exprimer dire ce qu'il a sur le coeur
et puis là on va dire ici ça reste dans
ce cadre là et
je vous parlerai utilisé dans un autre
cadre dans un autre contexte avec toute
personne etc
voilà c'est la règle donc maintenant on
va rester entre nous et puis on va
pouvoir commencer la séance à l'abri des
regards
la séance a duré deux heures rien ne
filtrera de ces échanges fin de la
rencontre
pour la psychologue le bilan est positif
c'est pas facile pour eux de se lever ce
livret d'un premier abord d'emblée comme
ça un militaire voilà c'est un homme
fort qui a sa carapace qui va essayer de
se blinder aussi mais quelque part je
crois qu'ils sont obligés aussi deux
doigts de se protéger comme ils peuvent
d'une certaine manière
après on se rend compte que quand on
leur donne la parole quand on crée des
espaces pour ça finalement la parole
elle se libère assez librement
aujourd'hui il y à un psy dans chaque
région pour accompagner les gendarmes
un renfort visiblement bien venu sur le
terrain ça une utilité pour aix qui
permet d'éviter le peut-être je le pense
le renfermement du technicien sur lui
même pour chacun à sa façon de d'évacuer
son stress de de gérer émotionnellement
une scène d'infraction sur laquelle on
se transporte là c'est
ça apporte une une vue de l'extérieur
mais qui reste discrète et qui est qui
et qui est utile à rosny sous bois
les experts ton parfois sur un os cela
arrive même tous les jours à l'adjudant
franck naulleau il est l'un des deux
seuls anthropologue de la gendarmerie
c'est une saignée que je vienne
récupérer au service et les a priori
c'est des restes de squelettes donc on
va essayer de voir qui peuvent
correspondre à partir du contenu de ce
sac
l'expert va donc tenter de donner l'âge
la taille et le sexe du squelette
mystère
on retrouve ici c'est juste la partie de
la scop salle avec les premières
vertèbres ainsi que les fémurs une
surprise peu ragoûtante attend d'autres
experts des larves d'insectes
là on en a ici aussi on a ici l'adjudant
appelle donc son collègue entomologiste
en renfort ce spécialiste des insectes
va d'abord prélever les larves
il leur donne ensuite à manger pour
qu'elle se développe jusqu'au stade
adulte dans quelques semaines ces
petites bêtes donneront des indications
très utiles aux enquêteurs la gdd larves
qui ont un état plus ou moins avancés de
développement mais je ne sais pas lequel
exactement mon travail c'est de dire à
quel moment les oeufs dont sont issus
les appelé l'arbre ont été pondus que
c'est eux ont été pendus à un moment
plus ou moins proche du décès donc le
fait de pouvoir déterminer les pompes va
donner des informations sur la date du
grâce aux larves les entomologistes
peuvent dater à quelques jours près une
mort remontant jusqu'à six mois
de son côté l'anthropologue à nettoyer
les eaux il va pouvoir les examiner pour
déterminer le sexe de l'individu
l'adjudant étudie la forme du bass avec
une échancrure sciatique très fermé et
une absence de concavité la forme
générale du public qui se trouve ici
déjà là on est quasi sûr qu'on est en
présence d'un sujets masculins
maintenant passons à la taille de cet
homme pour cela il faut mesurer le fémur
là en l'occurrence il fait 48 27 cm donc
on va taper un médecin dans notre table
on va pouvoir déterminer la taille du
sujet on a fait le calcul
d'après la table c'est un homme
d'environ un mètre 77
il ne reste plus qu'à déterminer son âge
la présence de ces petites ce trio ces
petites vallées qu'on voit ici
caractérise qu'on est en présence d'un
sujet relativement jeune entre 30 et 40
ans vraisemblablement plus près de 30
ans ça sera à vérifier agents taille
sexe voilà des indications qui
permettront peut-être aux enquêteurs
deux terrans d'identifier le squelette
mystère
quelque part dans l'oise
deux jours après l'autopsié qui avait
révélé qu'une femme avait été étouffé
les tic reviennent sur les lieux du
crime ont partagé des pièces ont fait le
mur au chocolat chaud aujourd'hui il
cherche des empreintes digitales dans
l'appartement de la victime
une tâche minutieuse réalisé avec de la
poudre magnétique et ce pinceau un
travail où il faut prendre son temps et
il faut essayer de le faire au mieux
possible pas trop mettre deux poudres en
être juste ce qu'il faut pour pas
surcharger les traces qu'on pourrait
découvrir pour ensuite pouvoir les
prélever correctement et d exploiter les
cadres de fenêtres les poignées de porte
le lavabo aucun recoin de l'appartement
n'est oublié et ça paie dans le bureau
le chef de la hat revient de révéler
plusieurs traces digitales bon vieux
tu vois un petit peu dans les mines
décrète digital tu vois les petites
roues s'est dit port donc si on arrive à
avoir une définition qui a ses propres
on peut travailler en meilleure qualité
j'irai de prime abord il semblerait
qu'elles soient exploitables
il ne reste plus qu à prélever cette
empreinte à l'aide d'un film plastique
elle mettra peut-être les enquêteurs sur
la piste d'un suspect le moment on
allait terminer cette empreinte la vie
rien n'avait eu qu'une seule ou une
parcellaire qui nous a donne assez
d'éléments pour pouvoir dire qu'il ya un
individu tiers qui est nu ou quoi que ce
soit ou qui nous permet d'avoir une
telle enquête
une suffit en inspectant le bureau les
gendarmes ont fait une découverte la
tour de l'ordinateur a disparu de quoi
éveiller les soupçons portent donc on
peut toujours faire un relevé une
recherche de deyme ça pourrait très bien
aussi l'auteur qu'il pourrait avoir plus
tôt le chef de la hat va donc effectuer
un prélèvement adn sur les câbles de
l'ordinateur pour cela il utilise un
écouvillon un coton-tige stériliser
l'eau ce qui est intéressant c'est tu
votes industriels et ça normalement ça
sévices et dans la tour par les petites
vis ici donc obligatoirement il faut
quand même avoir une certaine
appréhension des doigts pour retourner
ça on peut tout avoir non seulement de
l'année un peu trop de l'adn des
empreintes digitales
il ne reste plus qu'à essayer de faire
parler ces indices
c'est l'adjudant chef poupart qu'il va
ausculter les empreintes digitales
objectif identifier des empreintes
suspecte pour les mettre en évidence il
faut d'abord reconnaître celles qui
pourraient appartenir à la victime
à gauche vous avez la trace qui est
relevé par les qui a été relevé par les
autres par les techniciens et à droite
le relevé qu'il a été fait à l'autopsié
l'adjudant-chef va donc repérer des
points communs entre les deux empreintes
les marques avec ses petits points vers
vous avez le marqueur qui est là que
l'on retrouve ici j'avais le marqueur
ici qu'on va retrouver là qui est juste
en bas vous avez au dessus de ce premier
marqueur un troisième marqueur que je me
n'a que je retrouve également à ce
niveau là il faut 12 marqueur commun
entre les deux traces pour affirmer
qu'elles sont identiques
et là c'est le cas pour moi la trace de
question correspond à l'index aux droits
de la victime
donc cette empreinte n'est pas suspecte
passons à la suivante
elle donne du fil à retordre à notre
expert on trouve pas en 10 secondes
comme dans les séries c'est vrai on
n'est pas la télé et si puisque dix
secondes plus tard l'empreinte a parlé
elle ne semble pas être celle de la
victime
c'est une trace qui peut être tiers pour
l'instant avant confirmation par le
deuxième technicien mais qui peut être
une trace ce tiers ça c'est son pouce
droit
hélas hélas on les apports on n'a pas de
cicatrice on a rien conclusion cette
empreinte inconnu peut mettre les
enquêteurs sur la piste d'un suspect
encore faut-il qu'elle soit fiché
quelque part l'empreinte est donc
transmises à rosny sous bois au bureau
des fichier des empreintes digitales
dans cette salle les gendarmes compare
les traces en question avec les 4
millions 600 mille empreinte fiche et
parfois ça match
parfois ça ne marche pas notre empreinte
inconnue n'a pas marché mais elle
restera en base pour continuer à être
comparés péage de chamant dans l'oise
[Musique]
c'est le début de l'été la période des
grands départs
le psy bonjour jean raciale vous coupez
le contact s'il vous plaît vous pouvez
présenter votre permis de conduire les
documents du véhicule s'il vous plaît à
première vue cela ressemble à un
contrôle routier classique sauf
qu'aujourd'hui tous les tics de l'oise
sont réquisitionnés mais que viennent
ils faire sur un péage d'autoroute
sauf une opération coup de poing avec
quand même pas mal de me taire
le but étant de
deux recherchés
les yeux doux avec maquiller et relever
toutes les infractions
ce sont les voitures maquillées donc
volé qui intéresse les tic pour les
débusquer il vérifie si les numéros de
série sont d'origine occasionne un
numéro de série a nous devoir de
vérifier si cette frappe ou par erreur
frapper ou paraît plus ou moins correct
et pour cela il faut un oeil de
spécialiste
cette voiture blanche par exemple leur
paraît louche c'est parce que c'est sûr
tata numéro mais c'est pas un numéro
d'identification sur cette voiture
l'éthique relève plusieurs irrégularités
si on n'aime pas que signalétique qui
peut vous pouvez voir à lévis est alors
généralement ces plaques signalétiques
sont restés notre notre avis c'est
ensuite à ce niveau là vous avez le
numéro de série qui lui présente de
traces de rouille le numéro de série at
il été maquillé puis recouvert d'une
couche de peinture pour le savoir le
chef raymond va frotter la carrosserie
avec un dissolvant de l'état si on a une
couche de peinture qui s'enlève trop
facilement c'est que c'est de la
peinture de mauvaise qualité qui a pas
été traité comme ces traités en usine
par le constructeur en fait ça peut nous
renseigner sur sur le fait que le
véhicule aurait pu avoir été maquillés
ou peut-être accidenté réparé avec avec
une nouvelle plaque remise dessus
apparemment cette teinture a l'air de
tenir
[Musique]
finalement on a un véhicule
qui je pense nous a posé problème plus
par rapport à son âge et à l'entretien
plutôt qu'un maquillage pas l'opération
maquillage ne fait que commencer
d'ailleurs une autre voiture attire
l'attention des enquêteurs
à lire cgn
cette fois c'est une voiture qui ne
roulera plus qui intéresse le capitaine
antoine devait me cette voiture
retrouvée accidentée est soupçonné
d'être impliqué dans un autre accident
mortel celui là sinon on trouve un
motard décédé
on soupçonne ce véhicule évidemment
d'avoir percuté motta on va vérifier ça
pour mener son enquête
le chimiste prélève d'abord un éclat de
peinture sur la voiture ensuite il va
également prélevé un morceau de peinture
sur les vêtements du motard décédé
[Musique]
on va faire une comparaison pour voir si
ça correspond avec la voiture qui est
suspecté
pour effectuer cette comparaison il faut
d'abord identifier la signature chimique
de la peinture de la voiture pour cela
le capitaine place l'éclat qu'il a
prélevé dans un petit moule donc la
peinture est à l'intérieur du moule
on va on va couler une résine liquide
qui va durcir sous rayonnements
ultraviolets
le moule et placé pendant 20 minutes
sous cette lampe à uv
donc là je vérifie que ça pollue mais
rythme
et ça dure signe
et une fois que ça a durci notre expert
va pouvoir couper des tranches
ultrafin de l'éclat de peinture
cela lui permet d'identifier les quatre
couches qui constitue la peinture de la
voiture la fameuse signature chimique
on va analyser chacune des couches
successivement ce qui fait qu'on aura
une information très très complète sur
la composition de la peinture qui est
apposé sur ce véhicule qu'on pourra
comparer à un épatant tueur retrouvées
sur les vêtements d'une victime l'éclat
de peinture retrouvées sur les vêtements
du motard va lui aussi être analysés
ensuite les résultats pourront être
comparés donc là en rouge on a la
signature infrarouge du véhicule
suspects et et ongles la signature
infrarouge de l'éclat de peinture
prélevés sur les vêtements de la victime
donc on voit que tout correspond
parfaitement
c'est donc possiblement ce véhicule qui
a renversé ce motard la chimie a donc
réussi à percer le mystère du motard
percuté
mais sur le péage d'autoroute de l'oise
la pêche aux véhicules maquiller semble
plus compliqué à première vue ça paraît
correct bon visiblement il ya deux
problèmes
on va peut-être poursuivre un petit peu
le contrôle tiens tiens d'autres
problèmes nautique serait-il sur une
piste oui mais pas celle d'un véhicule
baptisé car le chien ne lit pas les
numéros de série trafic et pourtant la
truffe a apparemment détecter quelque
chose
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allah c'est quoi ça regarde la demande
en été on a des produits licites un des
produits stupéfiants
orange est devenu pour toi un véhicule
maquillé en fait trouvé de la drogue ça
ouais enfin on fait un peu tout
on peut pas laisser passer et oui nos
experts restent avant tout des gendarmes
et une fois de plus ils peuvent dire
merci à leur gentil chien chien à blanc
attention pour les couleurs c'est une
tradition dans la gendarmerie la montée
des couleurs
cette cérémonie a lieu une fois par mois
à la caserne de beauvais
l'occasion pour le colonel de distinguer
les gendarmes méritants et de commenter
les résultats du groupement bon monsieur
bernier reprise des couleurs avant le
rush estival
ce matin là le colonel tire son chapeau
aux techniciens de la cellule
d'identification criminelle
il revient sur le meurtre de la femme
étranglée tout d'abord toutes mes
félicitations au personnel de la cic
pour leurs actions sur un homicide il ya
quinze jours
l'auteur a été interpellé par là il est
actuellement dans nos locaux en cours
d'audition bon boulot mais je sais que
ce n'est que le régime courant de
fonctionnement de la cic continuer comme
ça rompez les rangs enquête résolue
jusqu'à la prochaine
[Musique]
verdict l'armée fonctionne parfaitement
et l'opérationnalité appartient à partir
en interne sont déjà là on est quasi sûr
qu'on est en présence d'un sujets
masculins
bon sang comment au pot ah bon attention
pour les couleurs